VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM.
CARILLO HERE.
DEEP HERE FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE PARK OVER HERE
FROM MOST.
PREVIOUS.
WAKES HERE WE HAVE A PLAN WE
HAVE A FORM WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA TODAY DOES ANY MEMBER WAS
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
SEEING NOTHING IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
FASTER SECOND SECOND.
MOTION BY MS CARILLO SECOND
LINES QUIRK SILVA PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO --
ID BY STATE I FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE PARK SO FAR HIGH
WORKS OVER ARE YOU FROM I'M
SORRY FROM MOST AYE REAVIS.
REVERSE I WAKES I WAKES I AM
MUCH OF MOTION PASSES MOTIONS
PASSED IN THE SCHOOLS MAYES JR